JOEL LEWIS: Hi, welcome
back to recitation.
In lecture,
Professor Jerison was
teaching about L'Hospital's
Rule, and one thing
that he mentioned
several times was
that when you apply
L'Hospital's Rule,
it's really important that the
second limit exists in order
for L'Hospital's
Rule to be true,
in order for the first limit
to equal the second limit.
So I have a-- but
he didn't give you
any examples of
what can go wrong.
So I have here a limit
for you to work on.
So what I'd like you to do
is try L'Hospital's Rule,
see what happens, and then try
to solve it a different way not
using L'Hospital's Rule.
So why don't you
pause the video,
spend a couple minutes
working on that, come back,
and we can work on it together.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you've have some
fun working on this limit.
Let's go through it
and see what happens
when we try to apply
L'Hospital's Rule to it.
So the first thing to notice
is that as x goes to infinity,
x plus cosine x-- well,
cosine x is small,
and you know, between minus 1
and 1-- x is going to infinity.
So the top is going to
infinity and the bottom
is going to infinity.
So this is an infinity over
infinity indeterminate form.
So it is a context
in which we can
try to apply L'Hospital's
Rule, so that's fine.
So it's an
indeterminate ratio, we
can look at applying
L'Hospital's Rule.
So let's try to do that.
So L'Hospital's Rule
says that the limit
as x goes to infinity
of our expression x plus
cosine x divided by
x is equal-- and I'm
going to put a little question
mark here because what
L'Hospital's Rule says is
that it's equal provided--
it's equal to what I'm
going to write over here,
provided that the
second limit exists.
So what goes over here?
Well it's the limit as x goes
to the same place, as x goes
to infinity, of the
ratio of the derivative,
so the derivative of the top
divided by the derivative
of the bottom.
So in this case
that's 1 minus sine
x is the derivative
of the top and 1 is
the derivative of the bottom.
OK, now let's look
at this limit.
What happens?
Well, OK the over 1
part is irrelevant.
The 1 minus part, OK, who cares?
The only thing that's changing
in this limit is the sine x.
So as x goes to infinity what
this does is it oscillates,
just like sine x does.
I mean, it's offset
and flipped upside down
because of this 1 minus.
So, in particular, you
know, sometimes it's near 1,
sometimes it's near negative
1, sometimes it's near 0,
and it oscillates back
and forth in between.
So in particular,
because it's oscillating,
it's not approaching any value.
So this limit doesn't exist.
It's not equal to
any real number.
It's not equal to infinity.
It's not equal to
minus infinity.
It does not exist.
OK, so the statement
of L'Hospital's theorem
says that this equality
is really wrong.
OK?
What it means is that
L'Hospital's Rule
tells you nothing.
You don't learn anything here.
So if we want to compute
this first limit,
we can't use L'Hospital's Rule.
We have to come up with some
better way to do it, OK.
So that's what's going wrong.
Now let's see about
doing this even
though we don't have this tool.
So if we try and
solve this limit
without L'Hospital's Rule, so
we want to look at the limit
as x goes to infinity of x
plus cosine x divided by x.
Well, think about what's
important in this limit.
As x is getting big, well
x is getting big and x
is getting big and
what's cosine x doing?
Well cosine x is behaving
like a constant but wigglier,
right, we could say.
So cosine x is always
between minus 1 and 1,
but, you know, it's
oscillating, but it's
in some bounded interval
there, whereas x and x are both
going to infinity at
exactly the same speed,
so this suggests a manipulation
that sort of allows
us to quantify that explicitly.
And so one thing
that we can do is
we can divide top and
bottom of this limit by x.
So if we do that, or
equivalently we can just
divide this x into
the fraction above,
split it into two fractions.
So we have-- I'm just going
to re-write it one more
time-- the limit as x goes
to infinity of x plus cosine
x divided by x is
equal to the limit
as x goes to infinity of
1 plus cosine x over x.
All right, so what's
happening here?
Well, all I've done is I've
divided that x in-- and now you
see that this 1, that was
from the x over x, so that's
a constant that's going to 1.
And as x goes to
infinity, cosine x-- again
we can think of it like
a constant but wigglier--
x is going to
infinity, so cosine
x over x is going to 0
as x goes to infinity.
So I guess I wouldn't
call this plugging in,
but it's, you know, sort
of just like plugging in.
So this part is going to 0,
so we're left with just 1.
OK, so we can evaluate
this limit fairly easily.
It just took a couple steps.
But we can't evaluate it
with L'Hospital's Rule.
So this is why you have that
extra thing in the statement
of the theorem that Professor
Jerison kept saying,
and that I'll say
every time I use it,
which is L'Hospital's Rule says
that the limit of the ratio
is equal to the limit of
the ratio of the derivative
provided the second
limit exists.
OK, so here's an example where
the second limit didn't exist
and so we can't say that
the two are actually
equal to each other, and we need
some other tools to evaluate
the limit in question.
So I'll end there.